you guys have all i've all got
interesting deals already is there
anyone that's got a deal that actually
likes to come on stage and picture and
if it looks good and if it passes the
approval of the audience then you're
going to get obviously uh 100 pounds
that's good i know if anyone wants to
have a bash
it's in newcastle
okay yeah who's your who's your team
this is the team are the three of you
going to come out on stage
come on out then come out on stage
normally when they when they're hit
stage as soon as they jump up that's
when people go crazy they jump up when
they jump up on the stage normally
people go outside crazy
actually
[Applause]
have you got the most of that
hold on let me have a look and if you
just want to make sure you don't stand
in front of the
screen any sex
for lima alpha
okay is this the house that's it yeah
yeah all right good so you're thinking
to build here yeah exactly oh
i like it
just keeping with the area as well okay
so this one could be a bri in its own
right potentially yeah we have spoke to
the agent and the end value for that
property once renovated would be 160. is
that what i said yeah
all right so basically you're probably
going to need to spend 5 or 10 grand
yeah
so it's not a great deal in its own ride
but it's got a big garden
look at this
and let's see if you can be able to
ability about
access so you need to put a gate i know
you need to put a driveway here so you
need to knock this down put a driveway
here
have of all the houses in the street got
garages it looks like not so i think you
would get planning here i can't see that
you wouldn't get planning yourself a
quick look at the street view so that's
the house vote yes so that property as
well once renovated it's got the rental
figure between six two five and six
seven five
right brilliant
and to build a little end house on that
you're probably talking about
85 grand
to build a house here
i mean roughly yeah so you probably if
we know it's going to be worth 160 but
it's done up if it's a brand new house
brand new no one's living it like we're
it's usually about ten percent more so
we're talking about 180 so you build it
about 85 grand call it 100 with all your
professional fees and everything
so you put 100 in you're gonna you're
gonna buy the house
you're gonna get a joint venture
apartment to buy the house you can have
the house uncovered you're then going to
get a development finance loan against
the house to build the new house
you're then going to refinance you're
going to pay back the loan and you're
going to make 100 000 pounds of profit
so it's a really good deal i could
definitely have six figure profit i do
think you get planning permission for it
um so uh what i want you guys to do is
i'm going to give you a 60-second
uh a 60-second meeting between the three
of you and then once you're at a
60-second meeting i want you to do a a
two-minute pitch and i want you to pitch
the deal collectively as a group and if
we light the pitch then you will be uh
you'll be crowned champions and the
prize is 100 pounds cash prize each okay
60 seconds starts now
[Music]
[Music]
okay you can talk to your neighbor all
right
how are
[Music]
these three gentlemen right here are
about to about to fix their deal okay
they're gonna pitch their deal and
you're gonna judge whether you think
they pass the test or not does it sound
like a good deal are they bx in or do
you think this is actually a good
opportunity on the table if you think
it's a good opportunity on the table
they potentially could win the
opportunity for me to take on the lead
and give them a 100 pounds cash
finders fate each so guys
guys
over to you
right guys i'm going to start by
showcasing the area in
the house is in and it's perfect for
maybe as a family as it's a
three-bedroom house and then with the
option which the boys are gonna explain
um
soon to possibly build a house alongside
it as well and it would be great for
a couple of families to come in maybe
we've got shops amenities we've got
healthcare centers next to it
and so yeah the area itself is a great
and
um it would stand out to
for an easy event i suppose if that was
the option that you would go down okay
which you're going to want yeah
yeah yeah
so you want to know some numbers yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
the purchase so the actual guide price
is one four five so worst case would say
buy for guy price we've estimated the
refurb for the just just the first
property there internally of 10 000
pounds to get sort of refurb for our
kitchen bathroom the rental on that
property would be between we're going to
say 650 because i said between 625 and
675
to the right hand side of the property
you want to go to where they go
so it has a large garage which we would
demolish and we would effectively build
an identical house like that next to it
it has scope to do that we've estimated
the bill to be 85 000 pound
so going over the numbers purchase price
of 145 000
and all in it'll be 240 k so that's
including all the refurb for the
property and build and then the gdv
would be 320 k if you work the numbers
out on that 25 of 160 k because that's
the end value per property and that'd be
40k so looking at that deal both deals
will be a no money down deal
and it would generate your cash flow so
the gross rental would be 100 so 1 300
pounds
gross per property no sorry combined
[Applause]
it genuinely is an absolutely fantastic
deal so not only has it got the bir
potential it's also got the additional
potential with it to build the adjoining
property alongside it's got a fantastic
rental yield as well as you said
potentially 650 pounds per property per
month an end value of 320 000 pounds
gives an 80 000 pound profit if it was
flipped on and area is fantastic there's
a school nearby and it's very attractive
for potential investors i think it's a
cracking deal between us
[Applause]
you jump on stage especially since your
high stage is this in front of like 50
people and pitch
that takes a lot of courage yes or no
yes
you know so mad respect you guys um i
think that the prophecy does look
interesting it is a lead it's not a deal
it's not a done deal there are further
due diligence we need to go in however
it is a lead um but
you know i i like it i'm interested i
like the area i like the fact it's got
an extension if i could package that and
turn it into a potential deal i know i
can sell it for five grand i can
potentially do it myself i've got
different options so i'm gonna give you
guys an option number one you could
either have 100 pounds cash each in your
hand right now
and then we move on with the rest of the
day or number two is you could say
actually we're going to try and keep it
for ourselves and we're going to try and
work out a way of financing it uh
ourselves you can keep it it's entirely
up to you of course
there's three of you you're all
strangers it's quite a big important
decision so you're getting a business
meeting about it how many royals that
they're going to need to have a
conversation and discuss this yes or no
yes
however how many rules do
rich people and successful business
people also make pretty quick decisions
yes
yes so you got a business meeting
together however i'm going to give you a
business meeting of just 15 seconds okay
your time starts now
[Music]
guys firstly firstly
what do you think don't tell us or
anything but what do you think what do
you think they're going to do take the
cash or keep the deal would you reckon
the deal
okay
drum roll please drum roll drum roll
all right so we got
um one
two three
four
five there's a hundred pounds hundred
pounds for you
and then we got a
we got a
this
one two three four five hundred pounds
for you well done
and then lastly
let's just check with good one two three
four five hundred pounds for you well
done then we've also got i've got a
spare twenty i don't know who wants that
i love it
sometimes
my name's ed miller my name is ross
thomas atkinson we've just been given
the challenge by samuel lee's to find a
deal within 20 minutes um we produced
the lead and we've just sort of sold it
on the stage to potential investors and
we've won the challenge and we've walked
away with 100 pound each very pleased i
think if we can do it in 20 minutes it
makes us think what we could do we've
got a bit more time and potential the
deals we can find in package um i'm
looking forward to sort of developing my
knowledge on other sorts of deals that
we could do similar to that as well and
i've got some good couple of myself now
as well and hopefully
people like these who are like and
want to do the same thing
[Music]